let's return to one of our top stories
for you this morning the average cost of
filling a car with petrol has topped a
hundred pounds for the very first time
but joining me now is the president of
the aaa edmund king good to have you on
the program edmund i mean it is an
unwelcome milestone to say the least
isn't it when the cost of filling up
your average sized car is over a hundred
pounds um did you ever think you see
this in your lifetime
no i've got to say it has been quite a
shock that today the average family car
you go out to the garage and you can end
up paying 100 pounds and 27 p to
fill up
that is a record and even over the last
day prices have gone up two p a liter
for petrol 2p a litre uh for diesel so
it really is becoming untenable
particularly for those on low incomes
we've already found from our research
that two percent of those in low incomes
are actually having to get rid of their
car
27
are actually cutting back on food
shopping because they need the car
because they live in rural areas or they
work night shifts and there's really no
alternative they still have to pay for
fuel
and that's why today we are demanding
action
okay well let's talk about that what
would you like to see happen given the
government have already cut fuel duty by
five pence a liter and do you think that
fuel retailers are benefiting
excessively one tory mp today
said that they are fleecing the
motorists would you go as far as that
i think there are two sides to this what
one is there is no doubt that in most of
the uk we need more fuel price
transparency we see it day in day out
the prices vary so much and whilst we
understand that retailers in deep rural
areas don't have so much through traffic
so they have to charge a bit more and we
we totally understand that would you say
a northern ireland system would work
better sorry to button we just don't
have much time
in northern ireland prices are cheaper
they're said to have far more
transparency there would you welcome
that being rolled out across the whole
of the uk we we've written to the
treasury today in northern ireland they
have a fuel price checker on average
their price is a six p liter cheaper
petrol and diesel so what we've said to
the treasury what they could do is cut
duty by 10p litre today and then
introduce a fuel price stabilizer when
the price goes up they can cut duty but
when the price goes down they can reduce
duty now that coupled to better fuel
price transparency to hold the retailers
to account would produce a much fairer
system across the uk and would help to
bring prices down
do you think retailers are withholding
that cut
well the first 5p we we've since passed
that and prices fluctuate so much it's
very difficult to see but certainly in
in the weeks after the chancellor cut it
some of them did not pass on the full
five peak cut and that's why we need
this transparency so that the government
can put pressure on the retailers to
give a fair price at the pumps
now you um as president of the a or
certainly the aaa has accused you your
big rival the rac of what you called
reckless speculation in driving no
in fact we we haven't actually said that
we haven't said that at all what we did
say so what did you say let's clear this
up yeah exactly what we did say is
speculation
throughout saying we're going to have a
two pound a liter price at the pumps
gives an excuse for some unscrupulous
retailers to push the prices up
what we're actually seeing at the moment
is the wholesale price has reduced today
and yesterday
so there is no reason in the next couple
of weeks at the moment for the prices
going up and sometimes
speculators have their own interest
in actually talking the prices up and
then retailers can get away with it so
do you think the likes of the rsc need
to be a bit more careful with the
language that they use
well i think some speculators do use the
fact that everyone's saying we're going
to have 2ple to go which is what the rac
said which is where this all comes from
yeah but we were not talking about them
we were talking about speculation in the
market and there are many predicting 137
a barrel
um up until christmas and the same
people predicting that were predicting
200 a barrel back in 2008 that never
happened but it did give an excuse for
those that benefit to actually put the
prices up so we do need a bit more sense
of calm we need the government to
intervene we need duty to be cut and we
need those cuts to be passed on because
it is crippling the economy and
crippling those on low incomes okay
edmund we appreciate your time thanks
for joining us there edmund king the
president of the aaa